[Music]
taken
[Music]
and right now reg brown taking the stage
guaranteed at least second placement uh
but he's going to need to pull out all
the stops to take out reigning champion
that flex my friend that move actually
is called the spirit of detroit look at
those muscles you know what interesting
that you say that it sort of reminds me
of the the the monument when you come
into detroit reggie brown just that
giant black fist yes yes indeed welcome
to the welcome to the midwest the paris
of the midwest look at this he really
has impressed me today oh but i tell you
what now the four-time reigning champion
quarter black yard look at him coming
out with the grace of a swan of course
his signature uh ranger panties
available at crowder shop which is what
this is all about but the way that he
moves in them is that of a dancer i tell
you what god ran out of charm when he
put his mold in the uh the oven there he
did he used all of it from what i
understand too quarter black was eating
a sundae before hold on one moment
here comes the oh there it is the double
glute flex
that is going to be hard to beat i'm
gonna change these pants he's a champion
but he is coming in tonight like a
contender look at this gonna flex that
thigh dude just did an awful job of
applying that tanning lotion and oh the
judges have to say yes it is well
quarter black carrot no surprise here
that will be his fifth
mr crowder shop title reg brown being a
good sport but you can just see on his
face that he has no clue as to how this
happened and i think that uh folks out
there of course can get their own
answers at crowdershop.com
dot com
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
speedy
that'll be twenty dollars
welcome
ahoy and welcome
to louder with crowder with dave
today's a very special show but remember
it's a live show monday through thursday
at 10 a.m eastern remember if we're
booted from youtube the show goes to
rumble podcasts mug club
all sorts of places i think i named the
three that are uh see there look it up
what all those people yes important look
right here and you put three syllables
in mug club
mug club yeah it's a gasp from the sip
well i'm sorry i was trying to swallow
no that's fair that's it that's his job
that's your calling party boy i say that
a lot every day all the greats
yes they do
third shares hyping up a lot already i
know all right so
don't be mad
you own the business
uh
i'd like to welcome gerald a how are you
sir i am fine yourself i am doing well
how does it feel over there is it is it
nice it feels better oh it does it feels
like i'm in control yeah yeah oh don't
let it go to your head it did it won't
i don't have the self-esteem token
ahoy how are you good oh yeah tim the
tool man
hey
and we have uh of course one of my
favorite humans on earth quarter black
hey hey little known fact i'm not
wearing pants right now it's just ranger
panties oh is that right every day
actually i did that i filed the
complaint with hr well too bad i'm
wearing them is that because you're an
all-white guy yes totally white
completely white guy what i was told
yeah i understand and in third chair we
have a very special guest uh stephen
crowder from the show louder with
crowder without dave yeah yeah yeah
because dave has an inborn need to
dominate
uh and uh well you can say next to me
too we have well we're gonna introduce
yeah yeah don't you worry
don't you worry i won't all right
where's that button
[Laughter]
uh one another one of my favorite people
on earth crawdaddy himself still not a
nickname dave it is a nickname it is it
can everybody should crawl daddy
i mean it depends on what party i'm at
yeah sometimes it's more of an
why do that is the you know the first
way that alexander graham bell answered
the phone i don't know who called him
yeah but it was a hoy hoy it was a hoy
oh hoy hoy was the original way to
answer a telephone wow this is a lie
he was a canadian that's not the only
good thing the canadians invented and
basketball
canadians invented basketball yeah
moronically do you know the story about
basketball no do you want me to yes so
they invented that the guy might know
his name was really like a basic white
guy named like like something like you
know john smith or like clint black
jerry west and yeah exactly clint black
would make sense and they invented
basketball they were throwing it in an
actual basket hence the term but then
they had to climb up on a ladder they
were like we have to go get this ball
out like this is difficult so then what
they did was they said i know we'll uh
devise a system with a chain
that they put in the basket so when they
would get the ball in the basket they
would yank the chain and the ball went
out they said well this seems a little
bit complex i know we'll cut a hole in
the basket so they cut a small hole in
the basket so that they could poke it
out with a brief silly
people are silly why would you make the
big hole so a country of ice fishermen
were like i don't i don't know what to
do this is a real puzzle it's really
hard to play this on the pond guys
there were so many white guys playing at
that point that there weren't enough
baskets
and let me see it wasn't this much work
one thing too for court because
everyone's been joking about how quarter
black is all white he is uh i mean your
grandfather is completely black yeah
he's really black yeah he's really dark
like uh wesley snipes yeah i've seen
photos he looks like scat man crothers
yes he does actually the shiny dipsy
right there you know the lightness is
off but the skin tone
spot on yeah yeah yeah sorry this is
your show no it is it's your it's really
your show i just i'm just at the helm in
one of my favorite shirts to celebrate
fantastic look at the sign look at the
sign yep it says with dave it says with
dave
until it falls down it's over to the
side
i just didn't have time you know with
with family and twins and all the stuff
and kyle written also this year late so
guys i just i'm gonna uh screw this up
so i'd rather dave yeah screw it up
dave here's a grenade you jump on it yes
you could tell he was really in jail for
a little too long because he kept
talking about the quran yeah the second
the cameras were off it was like a
strange hurricane in the green room they
were doing the tribal tattoo on his face
just a slave name a lot of tattoos done
with uh guitar string right yes and
he changed his name to kylan muhammad
yeah he made a nice toilet wine though
yeah unbelievable 98 point rated yeah
cherry toilet wine too use a little
champagne yeast i don't know where he
gets cherry toilet wine
[Music]
tastes like [ __ ] but it's made so fine
it helps dull the pain
hey dave you're not going to be generous
you're going to be at uh helium yes uh
comedy club in buffalo december 30th to
january 1st and then
big show february 12th majestic theater
in dallas that's right and i will be uh
for the f uh i will say i'll be opening
for him ah my first time just doing
standing up in a couple couple of years
can i watch no no everyone is actually
got free tickets here really you yeah
your wife can come yes but dave why yes
well she's cool your son can come yes
he's 16 months old he won't i
your third cousin is welcome yes
your sister can come
you can stand outside mm-hmm like how
jesse used to do it from uh full house
and listen to the music
no it didn't work look at you yes but we
will be there february 12th at the
majestic theater you can go to aeg live
for tickets and
stephen
uh asked to open which i was uh very
very happy about i'm just gonna say it
yeah we talked the other night and uh
well he's his stand-up comic and he
should do stand-up comedy and uh hey
agree just want to point out metal
detectors but
open carry and a lot of fans so
yeah just
you know
don't say it you got a room
yeah you don't want to look like swiss
cheese all right so that's a wrap come
on out
we will be prepared for any bs it's
comedy show yes that's why we have
gerald outside everybody down no i don't
i don't think so the metal detector is
just jailed with a wand that doesn't
work so yeah that's right try some and
find out everybody
it's actually a wand based on race yes
you guys are shitty culture
based on culture i'm sorry i meant
culture yes culture yeah
you seem like a cultured man thank you
what's your favorite wine again stop it
francia
barefoot anything in a box nein yeah
soccer mom yellow tail
you should see his pinterest
cold duck wait
it's his pinterest is just like it's a
it's a vietnamese football with wine
like i haven't had my wine today
you know at least once a day's like it's
wine o'clock somewhere
calendar killed steve i ate fruit for
dinner drank wine
oh i drank my dinner
he shaves his lady parts all right so
ahoy and welcome to love with crowder
with dave happy to still be filling in
today don't fret steven is still here in
third chair i feel like we covered that
yeah
and we have a great show
i don't read from a prompter uh we have
a great show pause for applause yes
we're talking about biden's recent phone
call to putin and covering the
highlights of the juicy smole trial plus
there was a wedding in the metaverse
what the heck does that mean okay but
first hillary clinton still can't let go
of the 2016 election
and it is downright hilarious
let's watch her cry as she reads from
her would-be 2016 election victory
speech listen to me
you will survive
you will have a good family of your own
and three children
and as hard as it might be to imagine
your daughter will grow up and become
the president of the united states
oops
i am as sure of this as anything i have
ever known it's a weird letter to get
before you america is the greatest
country in the world
and from tonight going forward together
we will make america even greater than
it has ever been
for each and every every one of us
thank you
god bless you and may god bless america
i i have a genuine question who's who is
she reading was she addressing herself
no it's the master clash uh did you wear
the master class yeah she was a master
class but she was very specific like you
will have three kids oh yeah
talking about her parents i think her
parents oh her parents yeah she labeled
herself a wonderful kid yes yeah
absolutely by the way she can't walk
forward she's like she's like a shark
she has to go back if she goes backwards
something with the gills i don't know
well you know how when you predict the
future always a little off yes so i
guess your mom got most of that right up
until the president party right yeah she
also believed that computers would take
up a whole room yeah
forever flying cars you will have a
flying car yeah and if it stalls you
will die robot made continues reading it
meet george jensen his son she harkens
back to a simpler day when democrats
actually liked the country and praised
it yeah that's right and said god bless
it yes greatest country in the world
that that's not today yeah she's like if
i don't win she continues
a virus will appear
the world will begin to collapse there
will be rise
and the seventh seal
yeah it will not be my fault it will be
the russians you will never stop paying
for this
all right take the president you will
love me
all right so now uh if you want to you
can sign up for that master class i
don't know what you're learning yeah why
would you not come on how to not get
elected and give a speech beto should do
it
if you go on that you can be like oh i
can i can learn to write from david
mamet i can learn to direct from martin
scorsese oh hillary clinton being a
[ __ ] that sounds all good
12 hours wasted of my life if you take
the advanced class she it teaches you
how to convince the whole world you're
not a lesbian
pretty good yeah
how to shave maxwell can ankles yeah
chock full of nuts dave chuck yeah the
whole time she's just using like a
crocodile dundee knife just shave her
legs chock full of nuts is that
wonderful ankle
how to not have sex with your husband
yes until he think about her resume
we think about her being somebody really
in public service she married a guy he
became president then she's she snuck
into an office being vacated in new york
where she had never lived she got like a
she had like share for like two weeks
she didn't come up through the ranks she
went right to u.s senator yeah and now
she's being appointed to who knows what
well yeah when i lived in harlem people
were like oh yeah did the clintons still
live there i'm like what do you mean
still live there like no never lived
there's nothing there that's theirs
i mean maybe there's some bodies not
that to say that no there's no nobody
would look for them there so it's the
best thing isn't the fbi following that
with a drone
like we don't need more footage of her
scissoring huma oh geez
sorry
you make those jokes all you like
doesn't third chair make you that's so
much more i know it's the chair i just
get to i just get to light a stick of
dynamite throw it in be like here dave
that's the best part
it's the best part of their chairs you
just say something
so let's talk about this uh why do you
think jesse smoulet pretended to be
attacked by his alleged gay lover a
legend i like how he's just allegedly
legend
go ahead and comment here why do you
think he pretended to be uh attacked do
it i understand that it was not uh white
guys it was two men potentially from
nigeria what yeah i haven't i guess he's
we'll see i don't know i don't want to
this is a guy there's two stand-ins from
amistad yes i'm just a huge fan of the
man's work yes yes by the way hey i will
say if you guys like dave phil and
hosting you enjoy you know it's a little
bit of a different day smash that like
button yeah come on smash black carrot
smash something i'm gonna feel really
good when it's like eight yeah yes
yeah it's like a biden speech yeah
well it won't be that everybody takes
away the likes that they do
this attracts the track i see the
dislikes we don't want to hurt the
president's feeling
by the way he just spoke at the bob dole
laying in state ceremony and i'm like i
wonder what it must feel like to know
that you might have a reservation there
oh yeah that whole room i understand
i'll be here
i've been so probably a few weeks i
don't know how long is he going to be
here
what happened that's my spot is that my
bed i think i'm gonna lay there a little
while did not pick one of those out i'm
getting real tired
i honestly and i'm not even be i'm not
trying to be a jerk
i i honestly thought bob dole had passed
already too he's 98 yeah i thought he
was dead yeah norm mcdonald's who played
bob dole on snl as an old man passed
before bob dole i'd already mourned him
yeah i didn't know he was still alive
yeah and they had difficulty closing
that casket lid they say oh really oh
yeah but i heard it just the bottom half
later there's a commercial remember it
was a pepsi commercial with britney
spears yeah and then bob dole was at
home with his dog barking and he's like
for super easy boy yeah you're like oh
wow that's great a horny old man
watching the super bowl half time
watching his 17 year old
yeah yeah exactly that's creepy from
what i understand though his coffin does
actually have a curve yeah
has a carve out got a little bull
trouble with the curve but i remember
that it was for the super bowl and
you're like i believe she's still 17.
yeah i believe and he's an easy boy
actually he says you want to go
because hey that's my
line with a baked beans dog it was
all right
let's talk about this guys on tuesday
putin and biden had a video call about
ukraine
that's good
some would no overlay there oh there it
is look at that okay
you can take it down i was reading it
biden apparently called for a
de-escalation at the ukraine-russia
border and u.s officials said they
already have a package of economic
sanctions to impose on russia should
they invade ukraine huge package huge
yeah
bob dole robbing big package robbing
thrusting package
we have rich
we have actually obtained an exclusive
recording of biden's prep uh before the
video call which is extensive due to his
geriatric state for us tom
there's nobody here
by the name of curly pubes no it's ron
clayne your aide
oh
sorry i i i thought you were
a crying caller uh it's okay i just need
to prep you for
all right you oh you got aids so
i gotta i gotta take prep
did we did we sex
no mr former vice president i'm your
aide and i need to prepare you for your
call with vladimir putin offer from
bullwinkle the president of russia oh
right okay look putin is massing troops
on the ukraine border we believe he's
going to invade sir okay okay oh okay
good no no not good it's bad we need you
to talk him down and use extreme threats
oh like when i i send
100 to bed without
dessert
or
crack
no no putin won't care about that we
need to take substantial economic
countermeasure sir oh yeah
measure the blinds
oh gosh look we'll stop swift payments
making it impossible to receive money
transfers participate in international
commerce and even use diners club
or
buy one of them new fancy horseless
carriages oh does anybody else smell
panties just
please just try not to talk too much
dude
who is this okay you know what all right
we'll we'll reconnect later sir bye-bye
okay turtles
yup yellow is buster hyman there
oh look i'm a jack
i hear it he works he caught his spot on
biden i don't know yeah it is fantastic
i know i i'm not saying it wasn't it
was either that or rich little
i'm really glad i wasn't here to
pre-tape any sketches me too
well this is what you get a b-minus for
it a b minus spider
how does a show like this get rich
little and bob dole right now you know i
know it really we're just hurting our
demo neither one
is that frank travolina yeah oh no for
some reason us and anybody under the age
of 72 missed that joke yes yeah i think
i don't understand
all right well it's just really quickly
going back please phone call the newest
thing uh that biden i think the white
house has proposed is actually
the ukraine giving them more land to
stave off an invasion okay
which is a terrible idea this is the
appeasement kind of stuff that cost them
crimea this is the appeasement stuff
that let hitler take over the
sudetenland it was like well if we just
give him this stuff he'll be fine he
won't attack you and it's like are you
serious like this we're really doing
this again so i know we're making uh fun
of mr budden here but this is scary to
have him in that chair right now kind of
like if you just get that third booster
they'll leave you alone oh exactly yeah
even you're fuzzy hold on i believe it's
a fourth booster if you just give up
your guns we won't have any gun violence
anymore australia no that's just my face
gary i have a fuzzy face
garrett why would you walk around
yeah his camera's like i don't know
which one there we go
very pretty close there you look at that
steven's like no no fuzzy go yeah give
me the lens filter the marilyn monroe
effect yeah
it's like tom hanks and castaway yes
he's more of a cheesecloth really yeah
you didn't visit epstein island no
it's a little different
that was where he got wilson
got a hole in it i don't know nixon in
the shower next to the prell well sad
where else had
you know he had a little sex with it
yeah you're out yeah oh yeah i mean how
long are you going to be out there where
you're not like oh well you're going to
do with that top hole let's go
spearfishing guys
[Laughter]
that whole movie advertisement for fedex
pretty much
yeah it's like right after the movie
like what do i do what chip wilson's via
fedex i don't know like i think that i
think the whole thing is it may take
four years for your package to arrive
yes that's really it's probably not a
good advertising no but it's like we'll
get it there regardless the guy's like
i've already had this replaced what do
you mean
i now have three children yeah
i don't need it but thanks for packing
peanuts i appreciate it it was uh i had
ordered a uh a vasectomy coupon
and now i have three rotten kids
i blame fedex
kids who wants daddy's soccer ball with
a bloody hand
[Laughter]
daddy's sticky hand printed sucker i'd
clean that if i was just a bunch of like
bottles of confections and seawater
thanks oh man
then wrap up helen hunt and bring her to
the window oh boy aren't you hat
wouldn't you be happy you dodged that
bullet
you just come back and you're like oh
nose wow thank god i crashed
look at the schnaaz ah look at you i'd
rather have sex with all wilson
again
not a joke again oh well son again oh
well son oh well well where are
something wilson he's a tender lover
in more serious issues no means yes well
sad means no
you got me tooed by wilson
how funny would that be wilson comes out
later
he's like look on on the set it got
pretty dark yeah it's just little just
little wilson on the wendy williams show
yeah well really i just he put me at the
end of a spear and that's not true well
now she's just drifting in and out of
life yes why do you think i swam for my
life when you finally went into the
ocean
yeah it really was a titanic ending you
don't do that because you just lost a
regular ball yeah that's when you lose a
sex toy yeah yeah that's a lover
yesterday guys let's be serious okay
fine of lovers fine yesterday the new
york times reported a lovely couple
named whoop you missed the coaster a
lovely couple
named tracy and dave gagnon that's a
good name real name
real name i believe that for sure tracy
gagnon
said their ideas to each other when they
hosted their wedding
in the metaverse oh
very sweet mrs gagnon's avatar was
walked down the aisle by the avatar of
her close friend mr gagnon's avatar this
is cringe man wow this is rough okay
she walked down the average
this is so sweet
i'm gonna re-read it pretend this guy
get from the top hey don't worry about
that last part i just can't believe it's
so stupid because i don't know what it
is
it sounds like some [ __ ] commie
gobbledygook
oh that's that's pretty accurate yeah
oh cool yeah miss gagnon's avatar was
walked on the aisle by the avatar of her
close friend mr gagnon's avatar was
watched
as his buddy's avatar
ambled up what the f yeah
and you're missing a period
christmas which is usually a problem
don't worry it's not like it brings any
less credit are you saying i'm pregnant
let's go for a third time
would you like me to read it dave uh you
know what i'm gonna do it all right all
right i'm gonna be the little engine
that couldn't come on your punctuation's
perfect i can't help it mrs gagnon's
avatar was walked down the aisle by the
avatar of her close friend period
mr gagnon's avatar watched as his
buddies avatar ambled is that right yeah
ambled up to the stage and delivered a
toast
and seven-year-old twin avatars the ring
bear and flower girl danced at the
reception until they were kidnapped and
brought to epstein's avatar island
i did not think he would survive after
death but he knows in the middle of it a
weird way to end a wedding it is it is i
just you know i used to get pissed off
when people would get married in like
you know chuck taylors
oh it's like come on if there's one day
for a tradition you know just oh just do
it on the wedding day yeah and then
instead they said like yeah you know
what let's get married and our virtual
boys yeah well virtual boy that's a good
reference
tell me yeah yeah i had a virtual box oh
really i got married in chuck taylor's
but we'll get to that so did i yeah
right oh geez come on
and i was in a chapel you'll like that
part i got married dressed
virtual boy that was the first metaverse
uh only it turned out it was all it was
like looking directly into a laser light
and it gave you eye cancer yeah there
was nothing virtual about it other than
the fact that you had to wear goggles
yeah and that was it and it just worked
with a game boy controller right and one
day my mom's like we have to take this
away and it was apparently because it
was giving you eye cancer yeah which
explains why my reading level is sixth
grade
how you miss the punctuation yes it's
all the red light it's not your fault
it's all that mario tennis it's cause i
played red tetris and it burned my face
i saw what messed you up it was the
period and then mister with a period
yeah right periods yeah i mean you don't
want to have two periods in a row like
that i mean then
that means there's a problem yeah that's
10 to 14 days of i don't want to deal
with it
you know what i'm saying
yeah she was suicide by calling her
[ __ ] yeah
oh
throw those pants away honey i don't
know exactly how i collect my life
insurance if it comes to it i'm glad i
have life insurance yeah me too yeah i
got just enough to
to pay for my car
so
to be buried in it yeah yeah i bought a
cat no coffin yeah but uh i bought a
curved
casket
[Laughter]
a wiener casket let's just call it that
yes he i i really i feel very bad for
you were saying darren that that was
like his uh
they were saying he was robbing the
cradle a bit with that girl yeah she's
but she's 80. now
that's an old cradle that's right yeah
yeah well
yeah it's really more of like a
secondary grave robbing yeah
you don't drop in the cradle as much as
the assisted sling that they have to
move around get me in the room
temperature pool yeah but she was like
way younger than him yeah
well joan rivers used to have a great
bit about viagra you know it's not
nature's way to have a 98 year old guy
chasing an 80 year old woman i don't
know nobody's chasing at that age yeah
no wheeling feeling after it's like one
of those pirate cuckoo clocks we're just
like
i would imagine yeah cruise ships most
of the deaths are just viagra related
heart attacks yes yeah for sure yeah and
the fallout they're in yeah yeah hey
everyone wouldn't you want to die that
way though no no yeah that's coveted
guys i mean like accidentally you last
four hours you bump into somebody who's
looking over the side right oops oh i'm
sorry ah jeez oh you see this i'm gonna
go play a shuffleboard with this thing
wait a minute i'm sorry you said this is
a negative side effect i have an
erection that lasts for four
hours i wouldn't like it is there a
doctor on this ship i thought i could
call it ladies quarantine it like
whatever it was a princess with covid
because all the guys get throat cancer
from raquel welch's hpv
[Laughter]
well now the worst vacation of my life
and the best yeah
i it's worth it
totally
damn that bridgette bardot
did they
do they have uh
wow that is a pull
going way back
i try to thank their generation
i'm wondering who's laughing on the
other end of that one though yeah as
long as we don't know her ex-husband
yeah yeah that's that dumb [ __ ]
but sure she did this to me yeah but
yeah
i feel better
well in case you guys wanted to know
apparently this this couple before they
actually met each other their avatars
met at a metaverse business event oh wow
and they promptly got into a fight
what an awful life metaverse couples
counseling i want to see what the
avatars look like in relation to the
actual people they've got better looking
no i really do because the guy chose to
be bald in his avatar he could have done
anything in the world he chose to go
bald i'm betting he's pretty accurate
and she looked like a barbie doll maybe
he's just so kind in real life in the
avatar oh no yeah like wondering how
close the guy was to the there's two
real things they'll pick one flaw one
will be he's actually bald in real life
and she has blonde hair that's died
okay so it does look like she has blonde
hair do we see her can we see her he's
got a hat on he's definitely bowling can
we zoom in or he's just super confident
like a reverse stealth because he's
gonna throw him off the center yeah
that's the best we can do by the way
metaverse looks really popular there's
like eight people it's like a biden
rally if you're going to create a
fictional universe why the courtyard
ballroom be yeah right it could be like
a castle yeah like one of the castles
yeah one metaverse person just sucks at
event planning right i was like well we
can only get lucky
yeah
the cake is late so come on high
school's beautiful metaverse marrying at
la quinta suite yeah yes enjoy
you get a free room ballroom there's a
tub i wouldn't
bathe in guys you're gonna have to i
don't i don't understand any of this is
it just figurines
no you know what
there was no emotion i barely get it
either
i believe it's like it's anime it's like
a second life yeah it's like second life
yeah yeah there they are oh lord
that's bad
he was honest he was honest he was very
honest i don't think she was quiet there
goes a guy with a plane
yeah and he is a nice one yeah it's so
strange
that uh the way that the guy like that
can get a decent looking gal well
they've got it online first money day
money well i know it's money i mean why
else do you marry a guy really
i've seen men i wouldn't marry them no
they're disgusting animals they really
are just pigs maybe she's like a russian
russian mail order bro she could be
she's like i love melvers yes i like me
i like for metaverse she's rolling i
like bald men with double chin yes it's
uh my perfect guy yes in my country mata
verse marry you yeah ah yakov smirnoff
how is it that you are so single yet so
bold and so cheeny
and
you are
which means in my country wealthy yes
you probably have lowest genes yes come
come
[Laughter]
all right all right let's let's get
serious guys yes why is there eight
because there is a serious topic trial
going on and i don't want to make light
of a uh a very uh sad situation yes i do
hate crime juicy smole trial
he leaves with juicy listen that is
serious correct pronunciation that he
requested at the trial oh yeah
trial is currently underway we're going
to go through some of the highlights
from the past few days thank god but
first a flashback to 2019 when don lemon
said he was contacting juicy
every day to show his support for a
fellow gay black man do i want to be
black
yeah or do i want to be gay he also
reveals that he calls like if you pick
one you're just going to turn white
and
he's day
i say i know you think i'm annoying i
can show you a text i really think i'm
annoying
you but i just want to know what you're
doing oh okay that's your mind he's
trying to meet somebody you can talk to
me because they're not out of us yeah
right sometimes he responds and now as
he does and he responded says you are
not annoying
no there's a lot of you you just don't
admit it cause you're afraid of your
friends yeah
and then jada pinkett tried to set him
up with will smith yeah yeah
good news
husband who's a cupcake yeah
matchmaker matchmaker match me a match
he's in a real me a fine bad dude let's
look past the evening i also have a
husband who's a scientologist
if you know what i mean
follow the science
come on
well on monday i don't know if you guys
know this uh juicy malay testified that
don lemon warned him via text at the
chicago police department did not
believe his story oh my gosh
are coming the straight whites are
coming
which kind of makes me think he knew
about it yeah maybe what do you mean he
knew it's like a horse because maybe you
got a tip sheet from a prime time anchor
that kind of well we're on youtube i
don't want them to say we said it
definitely so
maybe he knew even though he was texting
him saying he knew hey you know those
nigerians you paid by check and rode
around with in a car the day before
it's seemingly weird i forgot he paid by
check yeah amazing i remember when i
used to buy drugs i'd be like four
exactly uh an eight ball of cocaine
don't write that
can i date this yeah didn't jerry
springer pay a prostitute with a chat
with the check that's how he got caught
as mayor
of cincinnati that's awesome not only
was it a per it wasn't even a personal
check it was a city check
that it's perfect that is absolutely
he should be run out of town on a rail
instead we gave him a talk show and
listened to him for years i know but i
love him and he became a legend yeah we
went every day after school to my
friend's house to watch the jerry
springer it's a dumpster fire and we
couldn't look away yeah huh well i had a
friend who booked it for a while it's
just regular people yeah well no
occasionally they do get giant trash
bags but usually it's actors like my
friend sebastian did the
wilco show i think like two different
times oh yeah there's different
characters
yeah i mean you
like america might have its you know low
point people like white trash yeah but
not that right but not like to that
level there was a little too much i used
to love the boxing ring bell oh just to
get him going just tied the fight the
stone he's going nowhere fight now well
then the movie uh he made was called
ringmaster like it just became about
fighting yeah that's all the show was if
they didn't it's kind of like hockey for
most americans who don't watch hockey
like we love the fighting we're like
well that's how you settle it on the ice
i love it right yeah well it was that
the terry springer it was at the same
time where all it was was hockey fights
yeah where like if as a red wings fan it
was like if probert does that was that
holy day today
it was just blood on the ice every game
the funniest thing i don't know if we
can ever get this on the show but steven
sent me a uh what was it the avalanche
versus the red wings or something or
blackhawk oh i think it was yeah oh my
god it was detroit versus colorado it
was a rival of three nights amazing it
was just fight at literally the
when you had patrick wass coming out
there and then he just gets clotheslined
by the other guys when you have the
goalie getting in a fight yeah both of
them two two two there were two goalie
fights and i remember the commentators
were like oh boy uh we have 45 minutes
left but it's going to take a couple of
hours here
it was hilarious they're pulling the
goalie why well he was hitting the other
goalie yes
there's like no one left on the ice for
15 minutes and each penalty box is
packed to the gills yeah it's like
there's nothing funnier though when you
have a goal i mean they're dressed like
beekeepers oh yeah and the other guy
looks down and he's going to skate 200
feet and they know they're going to do
this
together he got time and he's getting
ready for him because the goalies always
fight the goalies yeah like a joust yeah
exactly
three minutes later
and boy that rivalry between the uh
avalanche and detroit was just legendary
yeah oh yeah legendary watch that was
like because now they try to make it
less physical uh which has ironically
made it more dangerous because the
game's gotten faster so they're going to
open ice hits you know it's kind of like
inside fighting and boxing like a guy
who's in close that's it doesn't do as
much damage because there's less
velocity but now there are more open ice
hits because they've tried to get rid of
sort of the scrums that take place and
so no keep them yeah well well sidney
crosby got more concussions in one
season than wayne gretzky got in his
entire career oh wow really because he
was uh he had two in mcsorley and
samantha oh yeah yeah so i always loved
the red wings or any player where they
didn't wear the mask and their face was
just ruined and they had three teeth
it's like you know that guy doesn't care
right you know true story true story my
dad you know this horrible father with
this one i love you but he used to when
i was a kid it was really hard for him
to tell me how to wear a mask and you
know face mask at hockey because i would
always hear him he'd be watching hockey
and he would see a guy with a visor he'd
go ah [ __ ]
no it's not that it's the protection is
fine but stephen you should wear your
mask no but to challenge some guy to a
fight while you're dressed like a
beekeeper i mean you can't be hurt right
yeah when you're ready
you know come on yeah it really is and
in the old days you had a price to pay
if you fought someone they were going to
bend your nose and oh one part of it was
like you had to like go do that move so
the gloves flew off and then you were
actually boxing which isn't easy to do
you have to get your gloves off fast
because they see you trying to you you
these guys would have a whole rhythm to
it yeah and now they've attacked the
jerseys down to the back of the pants so
you can't pull that over anymore i know
that was always the best get happy
gilmore them and just like burn that has
like a garter hook yeah on the bottom
that seems like a dirty trick when you
played did you play with helmets or you
didn't even play oh yes of course come
on i'm not that old i don't know were
they leather we had another helmet
leather ice helmets yeah an adjacent
mask
well the goaltenders wore those jason
masks they did for sure i love it it's
why just randomly he'll just go it's
tuesday every eight minutes
[Laughter]
no but if you taste that
oh somebody making toast again yeah oh
man i don't know what it is love it yeah
something about jessie smollett i think
yeah oh we were yes jesse also screw
that guy yeah a legend this is more fun
than talking about this idiot i mean
this uh uh yeah
beautiful
beauty
convicted
yes yet to be convicted wonderful
innocent good chin strength role-playing
gone bad great actor great great actor
yep jesse also
allegedly did a dry run of the attack
the day before the alleged hate crime i
thought that said dry rub i'm just like
a hate crime rehearsal dinner did yes
and
[Laughter]
just the families together
no other guests yeah we'd like to have a
limited menu
nothing ethnic what a piece of [ __ ]
sorry what a piece of [ __ ] yeah it
really is unbelievable to hire two
really dark black guys
who don't know any better just to tell
you know that's why he did you didn't
fill them in on the get do a dry run and
then tie a payless shoelace around his
neck keep it on for the cops then get
warned by don lemon and now try and
throw them under the bus just what a
what what garbage write a check and then
come back with an intact sandwich yes
yeah come on it's like never in the
history of hate crime did somebody go
fortunately i was able to save my bag of
wendy's yeah
this is really what martin luther king
envisioned oh yeah he was like please i
want the worst version of mess him up
mess him up is that a tuna on rye man
it's too far oh man put that down nicely
so that's that new toscano [ __ ] don't
touch that [ __ ]
on tuesday man i have a dream that a man
can fake a hate crime well and have an
intact subway sandwich at the end eat
fresh
eat fresh the need to fake a hate crime
because there are literally no hate
crimes why doesn't subway use him as a
spokesperson it would at least be
hilarious it would it's better than the
pedophile they'd probably be in there
with jared soon yeah i know jared is
holding up his pants like look at these
yeah i took him off in front of a kid
so i uh what happened
after the
after the attack juicy smoley allegedly
texted one of his attackers
brother i love you i stand with you
i know
ten thousand percent that's not even
accurate
you and your brother did nothing wrong
and never would and then he goes on
camera and says i was attacked by these
two guys
the opposite of what he said in that
text yes
well i love how we have to say allegedly
but you're reading the actual text yeah
it really is amazing the
the hoops you have to jump through just
to be honest yeah yeah well allegedly he
is blood type b negative where'd you get
that from his blood test but you know
when he caught himself pretending
somebody else did it yes yes smiley's
defense attorney tamara walker began
crying after she asked for a that's what
you want in a lawyer yeah began crying
after she asked for a mistrial and
claimed the judge lunged at her
as judges tend to do yeah they tend to
just come over that bench
start swinging she a public
public prosecutor no she's a pms uh
no judge is like i'm gonna beat [ __ ] out
of
the
best trucks i better watch it young lady
you're a freshman you'll get a fresh one
she's trying to come over the desk maybe
come on maybe just say it again ladies
and gentlemen joe brown might yeah he'll
be like you like to hit women all right
here i come i was a bad kid in detroit
yeah i messed you up bad man pajama yeah
stab you in your belt buckle and [ __ ]
cut your eyes out
and then i wear them on my eyes oh wow i
won't be able to see through my eyes but
i will find solace in the effect that
people know your eyes are also there
i'll be lit around by a dog what with
your eyes like pan's labyrinth only
they're not on my hands sorry i'm very
drunk let you
uh justice malay's defense
is trying to paint his attackers as
homophobic
citing a tweet from one of the alleged
attackers about frank ocean
[Laughter]
why are you following frank ocean you
know that i don't know what that word is
i have no idea
gay right yeah
yeah night i think you're right
yeah i think it was night well they were
darkest night yeah
yeah and a blizzard they were painting
them so
yeah
i bet they did know frank ocean is gay
it's sort of his thing yes yeah it's
pretty open yeah that only was ever a
hidden
frank ocean just came out dave oh really
yeah weird wow i never saw that coming
when when he started his career 15 years
ago and everybody knew he was gay yeah
wow
breaking news
did now jessie smiley texted that yeah i
think no no no no no no no no it's one
of the
brothers
one of the nigerian guys one of the
nigerian nightmares yeah they tested
they didn't realize he was gay yeah hola
binjo
it's a good name yeah it's a good name
for white supremacists yes
really yeah
we're about to go into some blacks ain't
that right ola benjo
yes that is right we hate them they are
bringing down our property values
you are correct pyramid grapes yes
hey you might want to take the ringlets
off your neck they could get caught on a
subway
sandwich can you get your hood on over
your lip disc yes
would you cut that in yes no
just make sure just
don't forget the bleach yes that's way
in case they catch us we can turn white
real quick michael jackson yes that's
how it works he comes back with like a
name brand clorox you dumb son of a
[ __ ] just get greater value
you i told you to buy in bulk night yes
you lost 82 extra cents of our check
written to do this
why does it say hate crime in the memo i
just probably wrote that fake hate crime
they're like that's why we think it jeff
yeah yeah this is all we need
but a wrench was thrown guys oh what
into the defense attorney's strategy
when uh juicy smole testified he did
drugs and masturbated with one of his
attackers well if you can fake a hate
crime you can dodge a wrench i feel like
a guy judging frank ocean masturbating
with someone boy that is the pot calling
[Laughter]
totally normal david
[Music]
yeah by the way please fact check that
people
call us on it we got the brothers wrong
all references available at like
comments yes they both just sound like
diseases you can only die from in their
native land right yeah
so
i'm bamboola oh please leave yes
don't let me take my shoes off i want
you to leave uh just sleep please we
here at lwc that's louder with crowder
with dave that's right
have actually obtained exclusive audio
of juicy and his attacker planning their
oh no in the bath house
[Music]
[Applause]
i'll give you 3 500 and we'll say it's a
hate crime from two white gas
but we
are
night jiren
it's called acting
i can teach you
but you're
not
a good
actor
well now now i'm getting all soft and
i have my feelings oh
i am harder now
your singing sucks stop stop insulting
me you want my money or not
i'm done i'm gonna go with subway get a
12 inch meatball
stick it on my ass and [ __ ]
yeah i did not review that sketch before
i know thanks for sneaking that one into
to be honest i was actually watching
your face that whole time
what's amazing is uh i'd like to thank
the panel there for the sound effects
made yeah well my mom's watching
my mom's watching from heaven
she's shaking her head you're just like
trouble you're right
that's what's funny is people are like i
think your parents are looking down on
you i'm like i hope not i hope not i
really at least i hope god's like not
right now yeah yeah yeah
give him some time is there another dick
joke there's like three minutes of today
where he won't be are you the penis
master are you that's a true story and
you will hear that story february 12th
where again i want to thank steven for
coming out and doing the majestic
theater with me it's going to be a very
exciting night and i was really happy
that you wanted to do that yeah well you
might be taping your special too indeed
yeah well that's right he's not stephen
is not coming out
no i didn't mean like that stephen is
making an appearance i think we can use
language too no no no it means yeah
exactly get your hate get your mind out
of the gutter jared you're better than
that yeah come on come on dude you're
better than that gerald listen
what are you going to write on that
check to me
yeah
things you don't want to know you know
what buy a couple of uh
tuna on on uh three cheese bread we'll
call it we'll call it even there's true
such thing as three teaspoons is there
not we don't have that's totally it's
italian herb and cheese and cheese i'll
make you three cheese bread right now
go get me three cheeses and bread yeah
no easy no daylight will not i call it a
davey grilled cheese don't make me come
over there i can do cheddar monster
swiss i don't care there's three right
there whoa those are not usually a blend
no they don't cook well but i'll do it
there's no cheese named monster
did i say monster you did i said munster
hey everyone because i know dave will
forget unless it's written in front of
him smash that like button
smash that like button
and comment below
show dave your life for stepping in
because yeah i am a busy man and i said
i know if i host today i'm going to get
everything wrong that was the bit i said
dave you jump on this one
you get everything longer than this
well you know what i can
[Laughter]
did i break wind did was that me oh dear
oh boy a royal one all right
all right you're welcome less and more
on mug club he's going to fart taps
that's right it's going to be
interesting yep yep i usually can only
get in three but you know we'll see
i can fart the alphabet it's very weird
and my doctor says i'll die soon anyway
please comment and check us out we will
be back monday right here right right
here oh yeah
right piss off youtube
youtube piss off
you